good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Riddle Sunday the day that I answer real
riddles for real nerdfighters ok hey
let's get started what gets wet while
drying a towel
what fastens to people yet touches only
one a wedding ring whose five six and a
half has a name that anagrams - i pwned
Harry foe and has fewer subscribers than
the vlogbrothers hmm Perry fine home
Fran Y pari harp oh wait a second you
know you don't mean yes no not really
really okay really do you mean it I'm
getting very excited okay I'm gonna go
to YouTube here on my trusty MacBook Pro
I'm pulling up YouTube and going to the
most subscribed directors I'm seeing
that the vlogbrothers have 40 1818
subscribers and Oprah has 41,000 365 now
Hank I am NOT an expert at boning but
that would seem to indicate that at
least according to YouTube we have pwned
Oprah Oh
oh my gosh I'm getting very excited uh
but you know I have been wrong about
mathematics before remember that time
that I thought that there were a hundred
seconds in a minute I am definitely I'm
going to confirm this I'm going to get
some confirmation on this okay Hank I am
now calling a Brotherhood 2.0 resident
mathematician Daniel Biss hi it's John
Green do you have a minute okay um your
name is Daniel Biss you are a
professional mathematician okay um you
got your PhD from from MIT is that
correct okay in your professional
opinion as a trained mathematician is
the number forty 1818 larger than the
number forty one thousand three hundred
sixty-five yes yes from a mathematician
yeah
yes even Willie's excited
I know Willie there's a lot to be
excited about we pwned Oprah we found
Oprah
I got a caller Hank hi this is John
green of the vlogbrothers um we just
pwned Oprah I'm not sure she's aware of
it so I was calling to make sure that
she knew I figured that you'll want to
call me back on account of how she was
pwned um but uh you know I don't I don't
feel totally comfortable with giving
Oprah my phone number because you know I
generally like to reserve my cell phone
number for people who I have not yet
pwned so if you could just have her call
me back through my agent Jodie reamer at
writers house thanks very much
and as always best wishes Hank it's that
rare occasion where puff levels are
caused by unadulterated joy Hank I can
only say that it is a testament to the
awesomeness of nerdfighteria and a
testament to the awesomeness of you that
we have pwned Oprah on the most
subscribed list this means as previously
agreed that the nerdfighters get to
punish us nerdfighters leave your
punishment suggestions and comments I'm
so excited about putting Oprah that I've
gotten sweaty into my glasses are gonna
fall off my face but Hank you are
awesome that I almost said I love you
but then I held myself back I'll see you
soon PS nerdfighters the details of
Paper Towns tour dates are starting to
be posted at eventful calm link in the
sidebar or more likely linked in the
sidebar I still can't do it